next guest leads the dating app that
famously puts women in charge of
making the first move now that company
is taking a bold new step in the
business world
this morning bumble launches its initial
public offering on the nasdaq stock
exchange
the platform has 42 million active users
today's ipo could bring the company
evaluation of up to
eight billion that's with a b dollars
it will make bumble's founder whitney
wolf heard is her name the youngest
female ceo of a public company right now
how old is whitney wolf heard she's 31.
she joins us now for an interview that
you're seeing first on cbs this morning
wendy wolf heard
congratulations to you i think okay not
only are you the youngest
the youngest ceo but you're also by the
end of the day you could be a
billionaire whitney
so did you sleep last night i'm
wondering what you're feeling right now
did you get a good night's sleep well
i have a 14 month old gail so i did not
sleep that well
but we're really excited this morning
and it's so great to be with you i wish
i could be there in person
i wish so too because whitney i remember
2014 let's go back you said it was a
very dark place
you were going some through some things
uh personally and professionally
and now you've clearly come out on the
other side what are you thinking about
today about your journey to get from
there to here
today is a remarkable day for me in the
sense that
you know there was a time that i thought
my career was over in 2014 and
if i can sit in this seat today it just
goes to show that anything is possible
and anybody can rebuild themselves
just starting over taking that first
step making the first move
and they can reinvent themselves when
they go through hardship without going
into all the details why did you think
your career could possibly been over in
2014 just give us the cliff note virgin
oh i had left my previous company and
you know all of a sudden i was being
harassed on the internet by complete
strangers and i lost
all of my confidence but what i realized
was you can lose confidence but you can
never
kill ambition and i was able to get back
up and try to turn my
my pain into something purposeful and
that led to the creation of bumble
you said after today bumble it will
still be business as usual how is that
going to be possible for you whitney
we are so focused on our commitment to
our community and to our mission
and to driving a good and ethical
business and we're just going to stay
committed to that
we are going to really focus on the long
term so
whitney i mean a stock uh ipo
is about investment in today's company
but also growth
one of the things i was interested to
learn bumble does is networking for
business and i got to say if my wife
caught me on bumble and i said
networking that would not be an
acceptable answer so please explain
well so what's interesting about bumble
is we have a bunch of accountability
features to allow you to use the product
for more than just dating
we actually allow you to disable the
dating feature
and it's time stamped for accountability
so that your partner or
anybody that you might want to show that
you're really using the product for
something
platonically or professionally will know
that you're doing just that so we really
engineer
accountability into our product and
allow you to meet new people no matter
who you're looking for
even beyond dating but whitney let's
talk about dating for a second because
we had
a match.com advisor on yesterday helen
fisher
who told us that match.com had seen a
dating renaissance
during the pandemic which surprised a
lot of us are you seeing the same thing
we have seen some really remarkable
shifts in behavior through the pandemic
one of the most profound
is slow dating where people are really
taking time to get to know each other
digitally first before
venturing into the to the real world and
of course this was
really imposed due to the quarantines
but something quite beneficial came out
of this that people are really
getting to know each other on a deeper
level and understanding if they're
compatible before they go and meet a
stranger in real life
so when you started bumble whitney those
years ago were you
hoping to go public was that your goal
when you first started this company
our goal has always been to just build a
really meaningful business
brand that creates impact for our
customers and changes the paradigm of
how we connect and
the fact that we've made it this far is
a remarkable feat for us but
we see this as day one of of the next
chapter and we're so excited for what's
ahead
another remarkable thing whitney is is
the tech industry is not known for
having women out front but but your
board is 70
female your leadership team is 50 women
how have you achieved this in the tech
industry
there are incredible women out there and
we have really
really tried to empower women not only
from
our product standpoint but internally as
well
and it is really important to walk the
walk and so we've really prioritized
gender diversity
in our business you also mentioned that
you became a mom 14 months ago beau's
mom that's your
your your most important title but you
also said it's been one of the chat
one of the most challenging uh times in
your life too you talked about
postpartum can you share how you're
feeling about that
how you navigated that well
mothers are remarkable i have so much
respect for mothers and
going through what everyone has gone
through in this pandemic mothers have
really
had a big burden imposed on them through
this and it's been devastating to see
what's happened to women in the
workforce and
you know i i'm very fortunate to have a
healthy child but
postpartum is hard and navigating
postpartum while running a business and
and going into a pandemic was a lot but
most importantly what i've
what i've learned coming out the other
end of this is just how strong and
remarkable women are and i'm
i'm honored to to be in the seat today
what's your favorite color whitney
wolfebird
famous gales well gail
take a guess i think every time i've
come on your show i've been in yellow
but you know what i think i know your
favorite
i think it's also yellow i know it's
sunshine and happiness and butter all
good things to me so
congrats to you today and bumble bubble
you're right all right on the precipice
of being the youngest
woman to run a publicly traded company
and by the end
of day might be a billionaire let that
sink we appreciate you being on with us
this morning